traitor don't laugh you're a traitor
Boris people in bewdley weren't letting
the Prime Minister forget that he didn't
come when their town looked like this a
week and a half ago it was swamped
as the river 7 came over the top of
flood defences now the waters gone some
here feel this visit was too little too
late
I usually for him here which is really
frustrating he didn't show up when it's
actually flooding he shows up after the
issues happened and acts like he's doing
the right job Boris Johnson was taken to
see the flood defences and spoke to
residents and Environment Agency staff
about what permanent barriers could be
put in he was met by a crowd of people
from the town as he headed into a
private meeting where only residents
who'd been invited were allowed in
[Music]
afterwards those who were inside gave
their verdict I think if he wants to see
what soon showed us the damage that was
done to her home one of more than two
dozen that flooded here in bewdley she
hasn't seen flooding like it for two
decades the visit tied in with an
announcement that the government is
increasing spending on flood defences to
thank the Environment Agency for the
fantastic work that they did take the
emergency services obviously for what
they've done but then to look at what we
can do to make sure this doesn't happen
again and were doubling the the budgets
that were we set aside for investment in
in flood protection across the country
from 2.6 to 5.2 billion
Paul and Tracy Smith and their children
have had to move out of their home the
damage will take months to repair they
met the Prime Minister and welcomed his
visit understand people's concerns where
was the Prime Minister and I said to him
you know I know you like a good
catchphrase and I said you know let's
get bewdley done let's get it done for
future generations and the last thing
that he said in the meeting was let's
get bewdley done and I'm gonna take him
at his word and if he doesn't but I'll
get back in touch with you
river levels have receded but
communities along the River Severn are
still on edge now the Prime Minister has
been and seen the damage
he'll next be judged on what he does to
protect towns at risk of flooding in the
future Becky Johnson Sky News bewdley in
Worcestershire